coach Carmelo Anthony really stepped up
in that game played played well dropped
31 points and was a difference maker
he's the elder statesman as you
mentioned and what's it like working
with Carmelo because you've known him
since he was a young man playing
basketball in Baltimore in high school
and now you watched him grow up what's
it been like watching his maturation
it's been great it's a great feeling to
be able to coach him you know he helped
us win the national championship he gave
us the money to enable us to build a
practice facility which most players
don't do he's given back to his
community in Syracuse New York down over
N in Baltimore he's you know a lot back
he's obviously matured as all young men
do and I think he's a leader in this
community I think he's a leader on our
team and he's a very very good player
one of the best offensive players that's
played the game I think he gets huge a
lot of criticism yes the New York Knicks
are good well that's not his fault you
know he's one player
I watched almost every game he's played
for the next because I want like a
basketball junkie or something and he's
playing well he's played very well in
New York but one guy can't win in the
NBA he made his team better in New York
he made his team better in Denver they
hadn't been a playoff team and
everything became a playoff team and
then the criticism was lately well he
didn't win playoff games in Denver well
he had to play San Antonio and the
Lakers and they both want championships
in those years so he's a very very good
player and he's got a good team he licks
and he's helped our teams win in the
Olympics and he's helped our team
obviously win a national championship in
Turkey so he can win but he needs to you
know be surrounded by better players
just like anybody else in the NBA and
hopefully this year rose and they'll be
healthy and the next will be better
he'll have a good year the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
you